you guys i am so excited to tell you
about this really cool project that i
just did with xbox
i'm sure many of you have heard about
xbox game pass but if not
it's a subscription where you get access
to hundreds of awesome games each month
and you can also play them on pc or
mobile thank you to game pass for
sponsoring this video and having me host
this show that i'm going to tell you
about
it's called signature rigs and in this
episode we build a completely
custom pc for carl anthony towns what
the hell
this is wild this is definitely the
biggest gaming pc that we have ever
built
i'll put a link in the description where
you can check out the full episode but
first let me take you behind the scenes
of how this all went down for those of
you guys who don't know carl anthony is
an all-star basketball player
and also an avid gamer now the first
step was finding someone who could build
a pc that would have the amazing wow
factor that we were looking for now
obviously we didn't have to do that much
thinking
because austin evans is a no-brainer he
has done so many amazing builds on his
channel but i thought that this would be
you know like a really easy build
or so i thought let me be clear i don't
want us to do that okay we're not it's a
bad idea it's a bad idea just kidding
so the next step after austin agreed to
take on this project i had to chat with
carl anthony about what his current
setup is
what he ideally would be looking for in
a dream pc build and
how we could help make his pc dreams
come true i really wanted to make sure
that we were putting everything together
that was on his wish list i asked him a
ton of different questions about his
playstyle his favorite games what kind
of games from his childhood that he
liked to play
and which games from the xbox game pass
library that he might like for us to
pre-load on his new pc
since of course we're going to have to
give it a test once he gets it so you
guys know that i'm a huge
sea of thieves fan and i was actually
really shocked to find out that he has
never played it before so i could not
wait for him to get his pc so that we
could play it together so now at this
point
i've got the intel and i got to give the
news to austin we did a bunch of
brainstorming to try to figure out what
would be the coolest way to deliver the
highest performance pc
but in the most shocking way so we had
all kinds of crazy ideas we were also
throwing around the possibility of
putting a
shoe inside of the pc and i said you
know austin can do anything so it's it's
possible he said he wears a size 20.
so i guess we can build a pc inside the
shoe
that would be a way to go about it
that's actually a good idea see i was
thinking
shoe inside the pc but then maybe the pc
is actually inside of the shoe i feel
like we actually could do that
but then i feel like does anyone want to
like is that cool to like plug like a
bunch of ports in the back of a shoe i
feel that might not be that
that might not be the approach i think
it would be cool spoiler alert that
that didn't happen well it did is
something that austin and his team
worked
so hard on creating like this is unlike
anything that i've ever seen in my
entire life they had so many issues
that at one point we were really nervous
that they weren't actually going to be
able to deliver this thing on time
what the hell it's crazy that is a
full-blown contraption right there
so austin went through so many hurdles
to make this all actually happen so
austin and the rest of your team
everybody who worked on that
congratulations
it is so beautiful it's so shocking i
mean it's just something that
it's really an art piece a normal pc
build is very simple but this
is completely just unlike anything that
you'll ever be able to just go into
a store and ever purchase like i guess
as carl anthony said before he's like
you know i will let the artist
take the lead and awesome that's that's
pretty much what you did
i've never been called an artist before
but this is definitely the biggest
gaming pc that we have ever built
so not only just in size and scale
but in performance i mean this thing is
loaded with the most high-end specs that
we can possibly get our hands on i had
to call in a few favors to get a couple
of the parts actually here
on time for you well i'm very excited
and it's it's funny enough that the pc i
was just playing on with
broke so this is perfect timing for me
it's perfect timing
straight to the garbage you got a new
one now
[Music]
like i was expecting like maybe like two
three pc
like uh cases together big but it's like
a whole art piece so after you guys
watch the episode i would love to know
what you think and would you guys like
to see us build another one of these
if so which celebrity would you like to
see us build a custom pc gaming rig for
leave in the comments below and i will
see you guys in my next video